in the latest post-death blow to the
credibility of the public health
establishment the quadruple vaccinated
ceo of fouchyauchi manufacturer pfizer
albert borla
has just come down with covid now lest
you conclude
the failure of the shots to stop him
from catching the virus would in any way
suggest that the jabs are useless or
dumb
or an obvious scam
the ceo of pfizer wants you to know that
he's very happy to have taken the shots
because he totally would have gotten
kovid way harder or something had he not
now unlike
most of the liberal automatons who
recite their fealty to the jab every
time they catch kovid the ceo of pfizer
ironically
seems to have been skeptical of the
shots from the beginning the wall street
journal reported just six weeks ago that
well into the pandemic as late as march
of last year
borla had to cancel a trip overseas
because he hadn't taken both his shots
in time
when that awkward news broke the ceo
tried to spin his reluctance to get his
own vaccine as an opportunity quote to
encourage those with vaccine hesitancy
later on
sure
he didn't want to get it
and i don't blame him for not wanting to
get it
it's a bizarre experimental technology
injected directly into people's veins
without any long-term data to stop a
virus that isn't all that bad for most
people and the shot didn't even end up
doing what it was supposed to do
i don't blame the pfizer ceo for
avoiding the shot
i just blame him for demanding that all
the rest of us get it i blame him for
pretending that the three or four shots
that he's gotten since then have worked
out great even after he caught kovid i
blame him
and our entire ruling class for
urinating on our legs and telling us
that it's raining for playing us all for
fools and for thinking that we were so
stupid that we'd never catch on i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment
yesterday was from holly green who says
i was listening to rush limbaugh before
he passed and he said that no president
has ever or ever will be arrested as a
really great
observation from rush limbaugh and a
great hope from rush limbaugh and
unbelievably rush didn't die all that
long ago but so much has changed even
since rush died and now we're on the
brink of andy mccarthy former federal
prosecutor says that seven chances out
of 10
donald trump gets indicted after that
fishing expedition that the fbi uh
launched on mar-a-lago just a few days
ago
that would be
difficult to come back from if
biden's corrupt doj actually arrests
donald trump actually indicts donald
trump
it would seem to me that is crossing the
rubicon that that phrase gets used a lot
you know we've crossed the rubicon i
think arresting former presidents and
current political rivals to the
incumbent
i don't see how you come back
from that will biden do it i don't know
the democrats have blown through every
other standard in norm wouldn't be
surprised could that be the beginning of
the death of our republic very well
could but speaking of death you've got
to check out
epic will right now head on over to
epicwill.com use code knowles the left's
persistent and loud attack on truth is
aimed not just at trump not even just at
you it's aimed at your children the
public school system mainstream kids
entertainment social platforms pretty
much all of our country's cultural
institutions have been infiltrated by
the left's quote not so secret agenda to
indoctrinate your kids with
anti-religious anti-american
thoughts and beliefs there are a lot of
ways that you can protect your kids from
these not-so-secret agendas you can
homeschool you get them involved in your
church one of the easiest and simplest
ways to do it is to take five minutes
tonight to write a will with epic will
a will gives you the power to say who
will raise your kids should something
happen to you and your spouse it can in
certain cases be the only legal defense
standing between your kids and the
persistent indoctrination attempts from
the left epic will as an online will
platform costs less than your next trip
to target they can set you up with a
will in as little as five minutes
starting at just 119 bucks plus you save
10 percent when you go to epic will.com
use code knowles take five minutes
tonight
write a will ensuring that your kids
will be raised the way that you intended
in the event that something happens to
you go to epicwhell.com use code knowles
today
speaking of getting shot
los angeles not doing so great right now
one of the reasons la is not doing so
great
one of the top reasons why la is not
doing so great is because they have a
d.a named george gascon he is a george
soros-funded radical pro-criminal d.a
george gascon was put into his position
to let criminals off the hook
because the libs believe
that
i'll give you the most charitable take
the most charitable take is the reason
that the criminals commit crimes is
because they get punished and because
society has failed them and so if
society goes really easy on the
criminals then they'll stop committing
crimes and we'll all live in a wonderful
happy utopia that's the really
charitable take on why the libs do this
the less charitable take or maybe the
more realistic take let's call it is
that the libs realize that they benefit
greatly from chaos and disorder in the
streets this is a
concept known as anarcho-tyranny the
idea that the the crazier things get the
the less order you have in society the
easier it is for the libs to go in and
take power and so
then the more power they take the more
they encourage this kind of disorder and
it's a cycle that that really allows
them to amass
quite a lot of power whatever it is
that's the situation we've got right now
in los angeles and so there's an effort
underway or there was an effort underway
to recall george gascon because he's
driving that city even further into the
dirt you saw a similar effort with the
soros installed prosecutor chase of
boudin jesus boudin whose parents both
of his parents were domestic terrorists
they were weather underground terrorists
and the apple didn't fall far from the
tree and this schmuck up in san
francisco caused even more chaos and
mayhem and violence and led even more
criminals off the hook and the almost
universally liberal voters in san
francisco chose to recall him
it was put up to a ballot measure they
recalled boudin he's out there's a new
new sheriff in town they were going to
do the same thing in los angeles and
then something really weird happened
the effort to recall
the d.a george gascon failed to qualify
for the ballot
and the reason is they they went out
they got signatures on their petition
they only needed
566
857 signatures
the recall effort got the 566 thousand
actually the recall effort got
715 000 signatures
that's great well past the margin that
they need to win
and yet
the libs
managed to disqualify
almost 200 000 signatures
so that brought the number down to 520
050 signatures that they said were valid
just under
the threshold requirement now
people challenge signatures in all sorts
of petition efforts that is just a fact
of politics the republicans do it the
democrats do it that's the way it goes
so you need a healthy margin beyond the
official number that is required for for
any particular petition effort
to disqualify
200 000
when the threshold is only 566 567 000
that's pretty unusual
it's also pretty unusual that the libs
would disqualify all of those signatures
at a time that we are told
don't check signatures don't check voter
id don't check people's addresses just
mail out ballots to anybody widespread
unsolicited how dare you if you in any
way try to verify that the person voting
is actually the person who's supposed to
vote you're a racist that's
anti-democratic and yet the libs seem to
have done that they seem to have gotten
pretty aggressive with that when it
comes to the recall effort for george
gaskin and what are the odds
what are the odds
that the libs would be able to
disqualify that many signatures to bring
you just right below the threshold
and keep george gascon in power this
right after the san francisco d.a
unexpectedly was recalled it's just
wow
really boggles the imagination doesn't
it
almost as though there are some
shenanigans going on with our votes
almost as though
the libs sometimes rig things or at the
very least they encourage election
procedures
that make the elections vulnerable to
fraud
this is not just me saying this this is
not just the tin foil hat
crazy wild right-wing conspiracy
theorists the insurrectionists the
threat to our democracy the liberals
admit this too
my absolute favorite story
of the last several weeks
starbucks
about as liberal a corporation as it
gets
starbucks just asked the national labor
relations board to suspend
mail-in ballots for their union
elections because starbucks says the
mail-in ballots
allow for fraud
is that
gosh is trump running starbucks now did
he after he left the white house did he
become the ceo of starbucks is some
crazy radical right winger running
starbucks no it's a very left-wing
corporation they're just willing to
admit when trump is not at issue when a
republic potential republican president
is not an issue they're willing to admit
that mail-in ballots are obviously open
for fraud barack obama said that 10
years ago for goodness sakes so
starbucks accuses the nlrb
of secretly coordinating with the union
organizers in the kansas city area
uh this is this is a dispute over
unionizing a store in overland park
kansas and
during the union vote they allowed
mail-in ballots and then what happened
i don't listen i actually don't know
whether starbucks accusation is legit or
not it sort of doesn't matter
starbucks a very liberal corporation is
making the claim that the mail-in
ballots
leave elections open to fraud which
obviously they do now if we're willing
to enforce election integrity when it
comes to the unionization efforts for
one store for one coffee shop
in coordination with the nlrb don't you
think it might be wise to implicate to
to implement at the very least those
same basic security measures when it
comes to electing the president of the
united states
oh but if you say that you're a
conspiracy theorist you're undermining
our democracy you're a trumpist
stooge
who's who's a clear and present danger
you're a domestic terrorist
if you're a starbucks executive that's
totally fine you're normal if you're
barack obama when he says the same thing
that's wonderful you're actually you're
trying to defend our democracy you're
trying to defend one man one vote and
yet when you say the exact same thing
as a conservative
you're a threat to democracy this is
i've mentioned this phrase a couple
times in the last month or two this is
what uh mike anton who's the author of
the flight 93 essay great conservative
intellectual he calls this the
celebration parallax a parallax being
the uh different vantage of a single
point from different points of view the
different position of a point from from
different points of view when it's the
liberals talking about mail-in ballots
for their own benefit then we've gotta
we've gotta get rid of all the mail-in
ballots because they're terrible they're
open for fraud when republicans say
exactly the same thing about mail-in
ballots no that's horrible that's a
that's a terrible threat to
democracy and speaking of labor
relations we are seeing a real
radicalization of labor relations
especially in minneapolis where a
teacher union just decided to
fire a bunch of white people on the
basis of their race things are getting
crazy out there when you want to protect
your assets especially if you're a fear
of getting fired you should definitely
check out birch gold right now text
knolls to
989898 the consumer price index has
reached yet another 40-year high and the
latest gdp numbers confirm that the us
is in a recession despite our current
administration's
desperate attempt to redefine what a
recession is now is not the time to have
all your money in the stock market or
tied to the u.s dollar take action to
protect your savings from a highly
turbulent economy now by diversifying at
least some of your portfolio into gold
and silver from birch gold group text
knolls k wles to 989898
birch gold will send you a free
information kit on how to transition an
ira or eligible 401k into an ira in
precious metals birch gold will even
help you hold gold in a tax sheltered
account for decades investors have
relied on gold and silver as a hedge
against inflation now you can too with
an a plus rating with the better
business bureau countless five star
reviews and thousands of satisfied
customers secure your future with gold
from birch gold now text knolls to
989898 get real help from birch gold
today that is knowles text it to 989 898
claim your free no obligation info kit
on how to protect your hard earned
savings with gold
the minneapolis teachers union has just
renegotiated its contract
as part of the negotiation
the union has stipulated that white
teachers will be laid off or reassigned
before any educators of color in the
minneapolis public school system if the
if mps needs to reduce staff
this is after the minneapolis federation
of teachers and the minneapolis public
schools
struck a deal
uh to to end a strike this was a few
months ago now we're seeing the details
of this contract
white teachers laid off first why
why i don't what is the argument for
that
the argument for that from the libs is
white people bad black people good
or the argument from the libs is white
people have privilege
and black people are repressed and
that's why we need to create a new
racial hierarchy where black people get
all the privileges and white people are
oppressed
that's basically the answer now
i think
every reasonable person listening out
there of every race
of every background
in every state listening to this show
would say this is a terrible thing
this is an absolutely terrible thing
we don't we don't want these kinds of
racial hierarchies we don't want one
race of people to be targeted for
discrimination
we don't want other races to be given an
advantage at the expense of the other
race this is really really terrible
who's pushing this i
i bet you
the people really pushing this along are
the white liberals
because of a sense of white guilt
because they bought into all this
ridiculous racial propaganda because
they bought into things like critical
race theory
this is really bad i don't if you in any
way believe
that this sort of thing is acceptable
you have you have no business calling
yourself a conservative
or even a normal person okay and i know
the thing you know the libs are going to
go with this because the racial identity
politics
has benefited them to some degree in the
past
don't the squishes are the ones you're
going to you're going to hear from the
squishes the conservative case for
racial quotas against white people the
here's the conservative case for not
allowing uh white people to get into
harvard or for forcing white people to
be fired first in minneapolis here's the
conservative well actually guys when you
really think about it
don't do it don't squish it's too clever
by half don't buy all of this stuff it
doesn't work it's not helping anyone
some people believe that they're really
pandering to different racial groups
even that i'm not sure works sean
maloney who's the head of the d triple c
the democratic congressional campaign
committee sean maloney says this stuff
really is not resonating with voters on
the ground it might work in the faculty
lounge it might work in the beautiful
penthouses of black lives matter and the
rest of the kind of corporate funded
libs but it doesn't work with voters on
the ground whether they're conservative
or whether they're liberal
maloney says i think sometimes we're
really clear on our own priorities this
is in an interview with the new york
times and we don't ask what are the
priorities of the people we represent
if i've had any success in the trump
district it's because i try to take
seriously the priorities of the people i
represent not just tell them about my
own so sean maloney i i've actually
known sean maloney since before he got
elected because sean maloney
now represents my home district in new
york place where i grew up he's now the
representative and i was
one of the
aides for the person that unfortunately
he defeated
after a redistricting campaign so i've
been on the campaign trail with sean
maloney this guy
is uh
he's right about this he's absolutely
right the district is sort of i guess it
went for trump but it's only because
there are very liberal areas of the
district and and very conservative areas
of the district as well and sean maloney
says
quote if i'm talking to a sheet metal
worker in pine bush he doesn't talk
about communities of color
he doesn't use the word rubric he
doesn't talk about the first generation
folks working in newburgh uh the the
first generation folks working in
newburgh
don't use the word la tinx most people
don't understand who are cisgender why
they need to put pronouns in their email
signature he's absolutely right about
this
and what maloney is trying to say to
convince his democrats to stop being so
weird is he saying look democrats have
good and valid reasons for why we
believe the things and care about things
i just find that we need to spend a
little more time building a relationship
with voters that is more respectful and
more patient with where they are to
enroll them in the changes that we want
to make
and maloney makes this point maloney is
a homosexual
he's he's adopted kids
he's he really lived in manhattan i
think he probably still does live in
manhattan but at least finally now he
has a house at least within his district
this is a guy who spent his whole career
as a political operator he worked for
the clintons i think he worked for
elliot spitzer who is a corrupt gov or
david patterson one of the corrupt
governors of new york who's a democrat
this guy is
this guy is not what you would imagine
as a kind of moderate just blue-collar
hard-working democrat okay and yet he
realizes if he wants to be viable
especially in this moment in american
politics the democrats need to speak to
normal people not weirdos who use the
word latinx and try to trans their kids
and do all sorts of weird stuff
he realizes that the the kind of extreme
racial and sexual identity politics that
the dems have been playing that the
minnesota dems are playing right now
trying to overtly discriminate against
white people that's not going to play
among normal ordinary people i love this
word he uses he says we have to build a
relationship with voters
we need to make it clear
if if you want to get anything done in
politics
you can't just focus on your own
abstract pie in the sky completely
disconnected agenda you've got to meet
people where they are and bring them
along with you
and get to know people and have people
like you i i'm not exactly best friends
with sean maloney but i did spend some
time with him on the campaign trail i
will say he's very good at this he's
very good at creating a
rapport with people
and talking to people like they're
really human beings and he's not just a
total robot who's pushing his own agenda
i mean i think the guy is just awful in
politics i'd love to see him defeated
but he's making a very good point that
his democrats certainly need to listen
to but republicans should learn from
this as well
this is why
trump is so
effective
there are a lot of reasons trump is
effective he's a celebrity he's
extremely entertaining he offered a
different set of policies than his
republican opponents in 2016.
but one other thing here
and i think it probably gives him an
edge over his prospective opponents in
2024.
he's got a real relationship with people
people feel a real personal loyalty to
him they this guy is a billionaire from
new york who was born rich and got
richer and lived as a playboy and slept
with supermodels and flies around on a
gigantic airplane and yet he's so
relatable people feel like they have a
real relationship with him
and the same cannot be said for
pretty much any other republican in my
lifetime certainly not to the extent
that it's true of trump
and so that's why trump is leading in
2024 and make no mistake trump
as of today is running for president in
2024. people can bury their heads in the
sand they can say no no i prefer this
candidate or that candidate or this
other guy would be better yeah sure
maybe i don't know all i'm telling you
is as of today trump is running the man
just released a campaign commercial
we are a nation in decline
we are a failing nation
we are a nation that is begging
venezuela and saudi arabia for oil
we are a nation that's surrendered in
afghanistan
leaving behind dead soldiers and
american citizens and 85 billion dollars
worth of the finest military equipment
in the world
we are a nation that allowed russia to
devastate a country ukraine killing
hundreds of thousands of people and it
will only get worse
we're a nation that has weaponized its
law enforcement against the opposing
political party like never before we've
never seen anything like this we're a
nation that no longer has a
free and fair press
fake news is about all you get
we are a nation where free speech is no
longer allowed
where crime is rampant like never before
where the economy has been collapsing
where more people died of covet in 2021
than in 2020
we are a nation that in many ways has
become a joke
but soon we will have greatness again
it was hard-working patriots like you
who built this country and it is
hard-working patriots like you who are
going to save our country
this ad goes on for i think three and a
half or four minutes and it's
it's all amazing i don't have time to
play the whole ad here but you i think
you get the flavor of it
that guy is running for president
and i don't care if you were the most
hardcore
ron desantis ted cruz nikki haley
tim scott whoever is going to run for
president you might be the most hardcore
supporter of those people
you cannot deny that is a powerful
campaign ad
and so i'm not i'm not saying this to
say trump should run for president or
he's the best nominee or anything like
i'm just telling you it is a fact that
as of today he at least believes that he
is running
it's going to be very hard to stop him
even if the libs arrest him even if they
throw him in jail the man still could
run for president and so when we're
thinking about other candidates or how
to run the campaign or what 24 is going
to look like you've got to look at it
from that perspective right now far and
away in all the polls trump is the
leading candidate
now
i'm very excited this coming friday
we've got
my favorite time of the week that is
going to be the voice mail bag brought
to you by puretalk a lot of people have
written in they've asked hey how do i
submit questions for the voicemail back
uh the way to do it is you just go to
my show regular place you go find my
show on the daily wire website and
you'll see it says uh you can you can
submit something to the mailbag that's
going to open up an email just attach
whatever audio file you want with your
voicemail back you can record it on your
phone or on your computer or wherever i
try to keep it to less than a minute
sometimes people send me these
manifestos that are 12 minutes long i
don't have time to play that on the show
but keep it to less than a minute mail
it in
we will hear
your wonderful uh
comments
and questions in the voicemail bag
not to drive this point home too hard
but i think it's really important for
the republicans now who are arguing over
2024
you have to grapple with the fact that
trump is the presumptive nominee
doesn't matter if they rate his home
doesn't matter if they indict him
doesn't matter if he's sitting in jail
you can run for president while you're
in jail it's already happened and the
guy who did it got a lot of the vote
eugene debs who was an actual socialist
the most prominent socialist in american
history that guy ran for president from
jail in 1920
and he got
6.8
or nearly 7 of the vote i think
so and you don't think trump would do
that
you don't think trump would run
wearing an orange jumpsuit from the
prison yard you know he would you
absolutely know he would
and so if the republicans want a
different nominee
there's they're going to have to
undertake some kind of herculean effort
because right now especially after the
raid on mar-a-lago i don't see how you
beat that guy
unless unless
75 years of mcdonald's finally gets him
and i don't think so i don't think he
will i think he's he's very energetic
he's very very vibrant
i don't see
unless he chooses not to run
i don't see how you stop him from
getting the nomination especially the
more information that comes out
from this raid
the latest i don't know if you caught
this headline the latest is that the fbi
goes in there
and they keep changing the justification
for why they had to raid trump it was he
had nuclear secrets oh no actually maybe
he had classified information well that
doesn't really matter he had all he had
binders of photos they took photo
binders of his and then we just find out
the fbi stole his passports
he had this is according to trump in the
raid
by the fbi mar-a-lago they stole my
three passports one of which was expired
along with everything else
what happens
immediately
you hear from the libs this isn't true
trump's lying it's not even you see some
news reports it's no the fbi the fbi
didn't steal his passports and they've
returned them
hold on wait what was that second part
yeah the fbi is total fake news trump is
lying as always the fbi did not steal
trump's passports and it's not a big
deal because they return them
how do you
how do you return something that you
didn't steal and oh okay well now the
fbi has admitted
and the doj have admitted that they did
take trump's passports
and they have returned to them why'd
they do that
why why would you take the man's
passports why would you take random
binders of photos if you were going in
to get the nuclear codes or whatever
because
the the
purpose of this raid the predicate for
this raid was extremely vague
if you i mean we have the search warrant
we've looked at we've talked about the
search warrant on this show it's very
very vague we have no idea what this
raid was really about warrants are
supposed to be pretty specific
and especially when you're talking about
raiding the home of a former president
completely unprecedented it should be
real specific and it wasn't
why because they weren't looking for
anything in particular this was a
fishing expedition
and you don't even necessarily have to
blame the fbi itself
because the person who called for the
raid was was joe biden's political
appointee merrick garland who's the
attorney general
do you really think that this was about
the nuclear codes and that's why they
waited 18 months to go get it and that's
why they waited three days after the
warrant was even issued to go get it and
that's why the judge who gave them the
warrant gave them two weeks to undertake
it because of the nuclear codes no it
was because of classified information no
trump says it was declassified and he he
as president had the right to declassify
whatever he wanted it's not about any of
that it's just about going in and trying
to find some crime that they have a they
have a a mark here
okay
and they're trying to find a crime to
pin on him just as they've been doing
for six or seven years
and no matter what you think about the
guy no one's denying that trump has
faults
no matter what you think about when you
look at that it makes you more likely to
support him you should say man if these
guys are so
freaking desperate to take him out
if they're willing to upend
the entire history of american standards
and norms
there must be a reason this guy must
really pose a threat to them
speaking of political attacks
you got a race right now for senate in
pennsylvania
the race is between two people dr oz
who as far as i can tell
is half a democrat at least and was just
unradioed
attacking pro-life bills very very
recently until he decided he wanted to
become the republican nominee for senate
and was castigating
pro-lifers
and
i i've never heard the man articulate
any particularly conservative point of
view in my life
but he won the nomination
for that seat so and unfortunately with
trump's endorsement so you got dr oz as
the republican candidate and you got
this guy john fetterman who is who is
the democratic nominee john fetterman is
one of the
goofiest
candidates i have ever seen on the
campaign trail here just to give you a
little flavor if you haven't watched too
much here's fetterman
and you can count
on us
to eliminate the filibuster if you
come out
and step with us
we will be able to stay and with you in
dc i gave away the lieutenant governor
governor in pennsylvania the only
lieutenant governor in the history to do
that and let's
let's get some stuff
done for america who would ever think
that i would be
the normal the normal one in the race
area with yeah
john fetterman makes joe biden look
lucid
jon fetterman makes joe biden look like
a rhodes scholar
this guy
not a whole lot going on between the
ears jon fetterman i'm not sure that
he's ever earned a dollar in his life
through actual work it just came out
that that this guy who positions himself
as a working-class hero he's the working
man's candidate he wears hoodies he's
got his little goatee thing he's a cool
tough working guy from pennsylvania
turns out this guy's basically never
worked in honest dana's life he was
getting an allowance from his parents to
subsidize his political career the money
that he was bringing in it was when we
talked allowance when i was a kid i got
one dollar a week allowance
sometimes and i didn't get it all the
time john fetterman was getting over 50
grand a year from his parents okay this
guy is such a
cartoonishly bad candidate
his his policy issues his his policy
positions are absolutely terrible when
they're coherent at all his health is
not all that great so he's been off the
campaign trail for a
long period of time when he comes back
on frankly he was doing better when he
was off the campaign trail
this should be a slam dunk
win
and here is how
dr oz is attacking john federer here is
the campaign ad that dr oz just posted
from his own personal account
now that john fetterman claims to be
recovering let's pull back his hoodie
and examine what's in his head
looks like he has some screws loose
what's this
fetterman wants to release one third of
all prisoners that's crazy
spend more tax dollars everything will
cost more that's nuts
slow energy production
gas prices will skyrocket
that's ridiculous
socialized medicine
get
[Music]
john fetterman is crazier than you think
that is and i don't think i'm
exaggerating here
the the worst political ad i have ever
seen
and i've i've seen a lot of political
ads remember i am not a witch christine
o'donnell you remember the demon sheep
ad you remember i've seen there have
been so many terrible
advertisements
i don't know that any of them have ever
been worse than that one because that ad
makes me
more inclined to support john fetterman
that attack ad makes jon fetterman look
better than he actually is
just makes him seem kind of silly
you know it just makes him seem kind of
oh he's got those big googly eyes that's
kind of fun
no the guy's very very dangerous
he's
his policies would be absolutely
terrible for pennsylvania
absolutely terrible for the united
states
he he should not be trusted with power
he's not who he says he is he's a liar
he's deceitful
no no he's just a wacky wakka wakka and
then what then half of the ad it's just
silly little marionettes and puppets of
aoc and bernie sanders who care what are
you talking about
it should be about fetterman and how
terrible he is john fetterman is a much
worse candidate than aoc or bernie
sanders bernie sanders has been in
american politics for half a century
bernie sanders is a fairly popular
candidate actually
even aoc she's pretty shrewd politician
why on earth would you take the
attention off of him
i'm not is is dr oz getting a payoff
from the democrats here
i don't know i don't know what to make
of it
it's really really unfortunate though
john fetterman this just came out from
washington free beacon he he uh voted to
free a convicted murderer who killed an
18 year old for heroin money he's very
frequently the sole pennsylvania board
of pardons member to vote for freeing
murderers put that in a campaign ad
don't put aoc as a jack in the box what
is wrong with these
people not a good way to win a race
maybe dr oz is just there to lose the
race i don't know i don't know what he's
doing unfortunate speaking of
competition
this one's good this story is going to
get me in trouble but i don't care i've
got to speak the truth
even if even if it's unpopular there was
a clip that was going around last week
from the little league world series i
remember when i was a kid when i would
play in little league i would watch the
little league world series it's very
nice and the you know the
actually the kids are pretty impressive
athletes given their age and there was a
clip that went viral though not because
anyone cares about little league or
baseball but because a pitcher beamed
the batter in the head
and then the pitcher took it very
personally and the batter
well the batter did something unexpected
you see beams the kid in the head
helmet goes flying poor kid goes down
luckily the ball almost
kind of hit him
where the helmet wasn't even covering
kids okay so then the kid goes to first
kid takes his helmet off and then throws
his helmet down and he starts walking to
the pitcher's man
and you think uh oh
is this are the are the dugouts gonna
empty is the kid gonna wallop this guy
and then this is really cool the kid the
kid gives the picture a hug because the
pitcher was very upset
and
i don't know i i assume the pitcher
didn't try to beam the kid in the head
but maybe and so the kid goes and hugs
hugs the picture and this is supposed to
be a really sweet moment and you can
hear the commentators saying this is
really really sweet
i'm sure
these are really good kids
it's really good in a way this is very
heartwarming
nevertheless
that was not the right thing to do
it was not you're not supposed to hug
your opponents
during active play in baseball or any
other sport
you're not there it's like a league of
their own there is no crying in baseball
that's true even down to
little league
that's true the reason that we have a
little league the reason that we have
junior sports leagues is to teach kids
the lessons
of sports
i'm not exactly a varsity football
player myself
okay though i actually did play in
little league for a very long time
wasn't wasn't the greatest battery it
was kind of like don balor i would just
lean into the pitches and then it would
hit me and i'd get on base but
the reason that you have kids
participate this is it teaches you
things about competition about
leadership about sportsmanship
about grit about toughness
you're not supposed to hug people during
active play certainly not your opponents
reminds me of ecclesiastes
there is a time to every purpose
under heaven
there's a time for war there's a time
for peace
there's a time there's a time to embrace
and there's a time to refrain from
embracing
and in active competition you were
supposed to refrain from
embracing
i hope those kids go out and get a soda
pop after the game i hope they go all
get some ice cream and you know talk
about what a great game it was and
they're very sportsmanlike but during
the competition that's not what you're
supposed to do there are a lot of
lessons here
for politics
okay sometimes i feel this is
forget about the little league for a
second
sometimes conservatives start hugging
during active play they start hugging
our opponents during active play we
grant the liberals so much
we
give away the game we even sometimes
attempt to lose with dignity we're so
sometimes ashamed of our own side we say
no guys come on we pull a liz cheney we
say i'm with you i'm really with you i'm
one of the good ones i'm a conservative
but not that kind of conservative
no we want there to be a good political
order we want to get along with our even
our political opponents
we want to be able to have a thriving
country we do have to live with these
people but there's a time to every
purpose under heaven
it's time for war there's time for peace
there's a time to embrace there's a time
to refrain
from
embracing
speaking of embracing
there is a new conservative dating app
out there
this headline just came out
kaylee mcinani's sister
president trump's uh press secretary
kaylee mcinanny has just launched a
right-wing
dating app and the right people have
written in here they write into the
daily wire all the time they say hey why
won't you guys start a dating app you've
got a razor company
you've got kids books you why why
wouldn't you start a right-wing dating
app because all of us are having trouble
out there in the dating world and we
don't want to date a bunch of weirdo
libs so kaylee mackinani's sister has
come out and done this
but
it raises the question obviously i have
not tried the dating app i don't intend
to try that or any other dating apps but
it raises a question
can there even be such a thing
as a conservative dating app you know
while the radical
gender ideologues decry the harms of sex
exclusive bathrooms you know single sex
bathrooms comedy specials
and dead named celebrities
kids are the ones suffering just
recently
the fda issued a warning that prescribed
puberty blockers the ones transgender
activists claim are harmless and
reversible can actually cause vision
loss and brain swelling gee who would
have thunk it the experimentation on
children has got to end to fight back we
must expose and defend the truth such
as was done in matt walsh's wonderful
documentary what is a woman with over 5
000 audience ratings on rotten tomatoes
what is a woman is pushing back against
the left's dangerous narratives help us
keep the momentum going by watching and
sharing the movie what is a woman go to
what is a woman.com what is a woman
dot
com
conservatives are about to get our own
dating app here is the young miss
macaneny to explain
hey guys i'm ryan i've got to tell you
about something i am so excited to
announce a dating app for all of us
conservatives it's called the right
stuff and it's launching this september
what i love most about it is that it's
invite only so not just anyone can join
first of all it's free to use and for my
ladies you'll never have to pay because
we all get premium subscriptions for
simply inviting a couple friends
gentlemen if you want access to premium
that's on you and by the way those are
the only two options ladies and
gentlemen the right stuff is all about
getting into the right dating pool with
people who share the same values and
beliefs as you so if you're a young
conservative looking to amp up your
dating life go to joinrightstuff.com
to gain early access we need to get back
to the right way of dating see you there
compared to tinder
and grinder and all of the other ones
i'm sure this app is way better
actually on the grinder point one of the
criticisms that the right stuff is
getting here is that they don't have a
same-sex dating option
and they're they're saying they're
open to the possibility of a same-sex
dating option in the future but they're
not sure they're not doing it yet which
raises a whole other question
if you've got
if you've got a same-sex dating option
can you really call it a conservative
app
is it we're the we're the conservative
gay dating app maybe it's an open
question i don't know i mean that's
what's being debated right now
what what does it mean
to have a conservative dating app is
that even possible and i come down on
the side of
i don't know that it is possible
uh ms mcinanny here ryan mcenany says we
need to get back to the right way of
dating
what is the right way of dating
that we keep swiping on people like
they're little commodities just to be
consumed
and like they're you know swiping on
little digital phantom images on a
screen instead of talking to real people
in real life but we do it on the
right-wing app not the left-wing app
is that the that's the right way of
dating no i think the right way of
dating is not just which app are you
going to swipe on the right way of
dating is how do you view people where
do you meet people
how who are the kinds of people that you
marry in the old days you would marry
very often your high school sweetheart
or you'd marry people from your town or
from your church
now that almost never happens now in the
old days you'd marry people that you'd
known since you were a teenager
now you marry people maybe that you
didn't meet until your 30s
i'm not even i'm not judging any of that
i'm not saying that's a terrible thing
to do we live in the world that we live
in that's how dating works now i know
plenty of marriages that have come out
of the even the lib dating apps and they
are great marriages so i'm not i'm not
mocking that i'm not deriding it i'm not
even saying don't do it i'm not saying
don't use kaylee or not kayleigh ryan
mcinanny's app
ryan mcinanny's app is probably a great
alternative to the liberal dating apps
that exist today
but her point is even more important
she's saying we need to get back to the
right way of dating and ultimately the
right way of dating is not going to be
swiping on people like they're
like they're commodities
that's ultimately that might be an
improvement
over tinder or grinder or whatever but
that's not ultimate we got to follow it
to its logical conclusion
the conservative perspective cannot be
let's do what the liberals want to do
but just slightly a little bit better or
more efficient or like a little bit less
crazy
the conservative
way of life cannot just be let's do what
the liberals did six months ago
not even five years ago we're talking
about dating apps we're saying six
months ago
no the conservative point of view has to
be different it's got to be a choice not
just an echo
of the libs
speaking of intimacy this story
uh i was almost hoping i wouldn't i was
almost hoping i'd run out of time before
getting to this story i have to get to
it i have but it's so
gross
it's i'll just say it
there's a
medical report out now
headline
evidence of human to dog
transmission
of monkey pox
now
you don't need to be
a scientist or an epidemiologist to know
how monkey pox spreads well i guess if
you're watching the mainstream news even
the allegedly right-wing cable news
channels you might not know how monkey
pox spreads monkey pox
pretty much only spreads
at gay orgies
and from people who go to gay orgies
about 98
of the spread is from that
and now
a human has given monkey pox
to a dog
so i don't we don't do a weather report
on this show and i know there's been a
heat wave i would look out in the sky
for fire and brimstone i would just
recommend on your drive home
just like you might look at in the
winter for hail i would i would say it's
much more urgent right now to look out
for fire and brimstone because
this is this stuff makes sodom and
gomorrah look like child's play
you know how the dog's got it okay i
know and you're going to hear all of
these
apologists for lib decadence say no
maybe they probably just got it you know
from a soda can or something no they
didn't okay we know how the dog's got
the monkey box
the question we have to ask is
why is this wrong
guys shut up to their animals okay
that's what happened all right i don't
need
you don't need you don't need to be a
weather man to know which way the wind
blows we know how these dogs got monkey
pox my question is why is it wrong we
all know it's wrong we all know it's
gross why is it wrong
the conservatives can answer it's wrong
because it's intrinsically wrong because
that's not what human sexuality is for
that's not what the body is for because
there's an objective moral order and
that ain't part of it
but if you're a lib and you don't
believe in any of that stuff and you
don't believe in right or wrong you just
think hey man you do you you know just
don't bother me you know just leave me
alone man
why is that wrong
you might say what the lib's gonna say
is well the animals can't consent
yeah we eat them
we kill and eat animals all the time
so we don't get their consent for that i
don't think they would consent to us
killing and eating them
so okay we don't care about their
consent so why is that wrong
the liberals
cannot answer
unless you're the most extreme sort of
vegan of all but it raises other
questions even about the way that we
that we
care for animals the way that we control
animals so uh we don't care about
animals consent sure animals can't give
consent period
so why is that wrong
and if it is wrong because of all the
reasons that conservatives say the
objective moral order because the human
body has a purpose because our sexuality
especially has a purpose
what implications does that have for the
rest of our dating life getting back to
the right way of dating what
implications does that have there you
know
the rest of the show is continuing now
i have got a story that i'm very very
excited to get to
but it's not for the hoi paoloi it's not
for all of you out there you cheapskates
who don't want to join the daily wire if
you do not want to miss the member block
of this show then you've got to click
the link in the description and join us
where i will be hearing from you i'll be
getting into my story i'll be hearing
from you in the comments and i'll be
talking to my friend jenna ellis about
president trump's legal troubles because
jenna ellis was president trump's lawyer
all right see you over there
[Music]
[Music]
you